welcome to this video playing do Cara
this is Serbia right and yep b5 yeah I
don't really think that this is any good
to be honest you can play be five when
g3 is already played but in this some in
this form I have my doubts it gives
white really nice center sorry center
and development term like has some some
some real issues here okay so yeah I can
play d 6 I can also take ok let's take
yeah Black has those extra center pawns
but white is really nice pieces and some
some pressure against this against the
central construction let's see I can
also go Queen a four-year may be Queen
844 route d1 White's development is
really nice IAM yeah c5 is probably not
well timed but yeah okay there is also a
six maybe so c5 might make some sense so
that i can actually redraw every retreat
the bishop yeah and I took a rating hit
in the last game that I lost and I
didn't upload that simply because I lost
that time scramble them and I I couldn't
help myself when I lost this I was
cursing so hard i was also say this
video was unusable I couldn't really use
it so I had to had to ditch this this
recording let's see what happens here I
can take the area and then c6 and what
exactly is the point here
and I don't get that just has to go back
now yeah the only issue is what is i
mean i can i can just do that right it's
a bit loose but he can move no peace
here see a turn bishop and stuff okay
this chicken b6 which can be a nuisance
maybe rupes you wanna to support that
mmm ok now it's got the chicken I way I
should've maybe I should have moved the
king after all
f4 is hanging you ah I want screwed that
up poo
yeah f or just hangs him unbelievable
from this position yeah that that's
probably that's the thing that happens
to you if you don't calculate a line at
all I mean I was just thinking this is
so ridiculous you will win this without
without would ever move whatever move
but you don't still has those loopy aid
stuff whatever okay
now I can go to whatever place can even
take everyone a few months but Luke edge
fries like it's normal I couldn't keep
the night only five unfortunately I
could have gone to f3 maybe but I don't
know it's some also not very very nice
losing f4 is the worst possible thing I
did then I have to retreat from me five
and we jut again just play King age one
or something and then I mean this is
also completely unnecessary here or what
does this idea Queen B 6 I want Queen B
649 f2 or queen bee six young can do
that 49 f to track track otherwise it's
smothered mate on 1g1 so let's see can I
somehow continue from here ninety-three
Queen edge fryer and wow amazing this
must be one of the worst games i've
played in recent at least in my recent
memory oh wow this is especially hurting
from this kind of position which was
like I mean I don't know the comp is
probably on plus five or something after
six plus four must be that kind of that
kind of territory just so bad well maybe
I should have tried 95 actually but okay
Bishop takes h3 as a move that it's not
so I'm not so easy to make as Adam gives
what
he allows Bishop c4 here why we should
see for night f7 ok let's see a night I
mean not 97 but 95 for pressure on f7
slightly surprising that he even allow
us that ok hmm I mean I'm still totally
lost but this was it even was it was
even worse he added here it looks like
some very very little hope due to the
activity probably you can can even just
play age 6 I mean I have to take f7 then
but I don't think it leads to much I
mean the ship takes I have to move have
to wait wait wait wait then the queen is
always on this rope here which is the
real problem check on f6 kinking here
doesn't lead to anything maybe this for
my cheek I'm learning ok
yeah the f file is open though this was
a side gim it is still completely lost
Kim Ji sub now that was good yeah what
you did there now the FRS is helping him
more than it is helping me any move wins
ah-6 probably wins but 96 okay that's
not so easy check check that's a check I
wonder all my pieces are unprotected
it's probably not going to end well but
I cannot calculate this in any way
properly but this is this is quite nice
yeah look aged 7 made checkmate I don't
believe this game what was this for
heaven's sake oh my god the first he
played really away I don't know yeah and
then I know this was absolutely the
worst ever from both sides yeah so 95 I
mean okay leads to this kind of thing
where I'm just flat-out winning but the
comp is not agreeing why why on earth is
no white not winning here this I don't
understand I just have to see sick
spawned it's an extra porn does he
really get it back somehow hmm yeah okay
I didn't really evaluate this correctly
then queen d 4 is much better for white
but i didn't think about that move at
all I just thought okay I keep this and
that's it but it's not know this is the
compass really just on 0.3 0.5 something
not very I mean okay it was still pretty
pretty awful tu connais d phi
but it's not leading to a direct loss
which I really thought would be would be
the case huh I mean okay this is this is
a ridiculous move yeah it's totally
ridiculous I had seen a six but I
somehow forgotten about it and then when
it hit it was clear that I mean it's
just a totally idiotic move I just have
to do something else and 12 even even
King edge one is better but the problem
is that whenever there's a six bishop to
anywhere and then look before everyone
saying you know I totally I totally
didn't understand what was going on yeah
and he I mean I just I'm just toast here
it's just just a terribly bad position
she for Jim Jack Jack jamming okay 93
maybe was better but it is just lost
yeah you can can really just the compass
compass on 000 after that what night f7
King g7 and now it wants to go 98 with
an advantage for white yeah in a
tactical in a purely tactical position I
mean okay the computers of course like
God yeah in a tactical position and I'm
not really great and this leads to some
funny things nowadays now and then 98
with an advantage for white the computer
gives 98 rook e8 Bishop here and then
Bishop to be seven what of what a great
line and if the funniest thing is that
why it is really somewhat coordinated
yeah this is protecting each other this
is protecting and I'm not made on the
background which is also week that's
amazing
I went here which is bad yeah it's it's
worse at least in comparison but it's
not losing funny enough check and here
it's a slight edge for white at least as
that's the initial computer evaluation
and here I mean here the real problem is
you have like I don't know the clock
chimes I'm not there I have to change
something in the setup um you have no
time on the clock and all pieces of
whites are undefended yeah I just you
just have to get with your go with your
gut feeling okay this is bad you too oh
no it's not bad it's equal but look at
four is the move that he has to play
yeah that makes some sense yeah look it
takes h4 and e4 hangs the line that the
computer gives us this actually and then
back which is certainly not great i need
comparison but computer oops computer
gives to this equal with this and look
ff7 for some kind of draw at the end
yeah and he here and he went right into
this checkmate and Chum amazing really
amazing yeah I didn't understand
anything in this game I really thought
that I would be like winning yeah after
this but this is not the case black is
somehow kicking those active pieces bag
and has come to play and then when I
thought I would be completely lost there
was still at least some chances which
which I really didn't think so amazing
game I mean not a good game but what an
up-and-down struggle okay well thanks
for watching